my name is Angus McFadden I'm a
silversmith an engraver I've been doing
it since 1984 engraving is one of these
things that when it becomes known you
engrave then you can ask to do jobs like
this make a sundial replica engraving is
basically drawing on metal so the first
thing you have to do is to draw on the
metal and the simplest thing to use is a
pencil but then once you've drawn on the
metal you need to mark it in more
permanently before you start engraving
so we use a scribe to do that and that
scratches the metal if you like
scratches the surface of the metal
sufficiently that you have a permanent
line that you can then follow with the
graver and the graver
is cutting metal so you're removing
metal which leaves you or a line of all
sorts of depths or widths according to
the job babe versatile protis brass is a
material that's used a lot for look
particularly for this type of thing you
know instruments in the in the past and
this brass for this sundial actually
although it is machining brass it's just
quite a high lead content in the other
way it's actually quite hard to cut
engraving is it extremely time-consuming
there were no shortcuts as there were to
hide there's no cheating you've got to
do it as nicely as you possibly can it
can be tiring when you're on a big job
and it's just day in day out cutting
away but at the same time I love it and
I think if you didn't enjoy doing it it
would just be a chore I know you
wouldn't do totally good work I don't
think either even now when you do a nice
cut that you're really pleased with it's
quite exciting still it was really
fascinating to look closely at the
original sundial I see the remarks at
the beginnings or ends of some of the
cuts which most people wouldn't even
notice and they're not mistakes or not
errors but they're marks which probably
only an engraver will notice there's
this instant connect with the person
that did it and that's lovely you know
to go back that many years and just have
that instant connection with the person
who did it you say oh yeah I know it was
good on there I know what you did there
that personal touch is something which
you only get when somebody's sat down
and done it themselves yeah
you